et elles sont absurdes étant donné la complexité de l'humanité
et notre monde largement interconnecté, bien que très inégal.
Aujourd'hui, nous voyons des revendications à la tradition
qui s'imaginent être anciennes
changer rapidement devant nos yeux.
J'ai été élevé dans les années 70 près de Wembley
entouré de familles asiatiques, anglaises, antillaises et irlandaises
et le Front National néo-Nazi avaient une énorme influence
avec des manifestations et des attaques régulières,
une menace permanente
et souvent, une réalité de violence à notre encontre
dans les rues, dans nos maisons,
en général par les néo-nazis et d'autres racistes.
Lors d'une élection, un prospectus était arrivé dans notre boîte aux lettres
avec la photo d'un candidat du Front National pour notre zone.
Et la photo
était celle de notre voisin d'à côté.
Il avait déjà menacé de me tirer dessus pendant que je jouais dans le jardin
et lors de nombreux week-ends,
des activistes à la tête rasée arrivaient chez lui
et en sortaient avec des dizaines de pancartes
criant que nous devrions rentrer chez nous.
Mais aujourd'hui, il est l'un des meilleurs amis de ma mère.
C'est un homme très charmant et gentil
et à un moment donné, dans son voyage politique hors du fascisme,
il a embrassé une idée plus ouverte de l'humanité.
Il y avait une famille hindoue que nous connaissions bien –
la vie dans notre rue était un peu comme le décor d'un soap opéra asiatique.
Tout le monde se mêlait des affaires des autres,
que vous le vouliez ou non.
Vous n'aviez vraiment pas le choix.
Mais dans cette famille, il y avait un petit garçon calme
qui allait à l'école avec moi.
Après avoir quitté l'école, je n'ai plus entendu parler de lui,
à part qu'il était parti en Inde.
Aux alentours de l'an 2000,
je me rappelle être tombé sur ce petit livre.
Ce livre était inhabituel
parce qu'il était écrit par un partisan britannique d'Al Qaïda
et l'auteur y appelle à des attentats en Grande-Bretagne.
C'était en 1999,
donc le 11 Septembre et l'invasion de l'Irak étaient encore dans le futur
et il a aidé à localiser des cibles d'attentats à New York.
Il a appris à d'autres comment faire une bombe sale
destinée à être utilisée dans le métro londonien
et il a comploté une énorme campagne d'attentats dans les rues de Londres.
Il est détenu dans une prison de très haute sécurité au Royaume-Uni
et est l'une des figures les plus importantes d'Al Qaïda
à avoir été arrêté en Grande-Bretagne.
L'auteur de ce livre
est le même petit garçon calme
qui est allé à l'école avec moi.
Un garçon hindou de Grande-Bretagne est devenu un combattant pour Al Qaïda
et l'un des terroristes les plus recherchés au monde.
Il a rejeté ce que les gens appelleraient
son identité hindoue, indienne ou britannique
et il est devenu quelqu'un d'autre.
Il a refusé d'être qui il était.
Il s'est recréé
et la poursuite d'un tel chemin est très commune
pour les jeunes hommes et femmes
qui se sont engagés avec Al Qaïda, l'État Islamique
ou d'autres groupes armés internationaux.
Le porte-parole d'Al Qaïda est un Blanc américain
d'origine juive et catholique
et ni lui ni le garçon de mon école
n'étaient d'origine musulmane.
Il est inutile de leur demander d'où ils viennent.
La question plus importante est où vont-ils.
Je voudrais aussi vous dire
que le même chemin est entrepris par ces jeunes hommes et femmes
élevés dans des familles d'origine musulmane.
La plupart de ceux qui rejoignent Al Qaïda et d'autres groupes djihadistes salafistes
en provenance d'Europe, d'Asie, d'Amérique du Nord
et dans beaucoup de cas du Moyen-Orient
sont ceux qui ont rejeté leurs milieux dans leur intégralité
pour devenir, en somme, de nouvelles personnes.
Ils passent un temps considérable à attaquer les milieux de leurs parents
comme étant profanes, impurs, blasphématoires,
la mauvaise version de l'Islam
et à la place, leur vision
est la vision fantastique d'une apocalypse cosmique.
C'est une vision de renaissance.
Rejetez votre passé, votre société, votre famille et vos amis
puisqu'ils sont tous impurs.
À la place, devenez quelqu'un d'autre,
votre vrai vous,
votre vous authentique.
Ceci n'a rien à voir avec un retour dans le passé,
mais avec l'utilisation d'une contrefaçon du passé
pour imaginer un futur épouvantable qui commence aujourd'hui, en l'an zéro.
C'est pour ça que 80% des victimes d'Al Qaïda et de l'État Islamique
sont des gens d'origine musulmane.
La première action des groupes djihadistes lorsqu'ils s'emparent d'une région
est de détruire les institutions musulmanes existantes,
telles que les mosquées, les sanctuaires, les prêtres et les pratiques.
Leur but principal est de contrôler et de punir les gens de l'intérieur,
de décider des endroits autorisés aux femmes,
de l'habillement, des relations familiales,
des croyances jusqu'aux moindres détails de la prière.
Les médias nous font croire
qu'ils en ont après nous dans l'Occident,
mais ils en sont surtout après ceux de différentes origines musulmanes.
Selon eux, aucun autre musulman ne peut jamais être assez pur.
Les croyances et pratiques ordinaires qui existent depuis des siècles
sont ainsi considérées comme impures
par des adolescents de Birmingham ou de Londres
qui ne savent rien
des histoires qu'ils anéantissent avec tant de joie.
Leur revendication à la tradition est en guerre avec l'histoire,
mais ils sont toutefois très certains de leur pureté à eux
et de l'impureté des autres.
La pureté,
la certitude,
le retour à la tradition authentique.
Cette quête peut mener à des visions mortelles
de sociétés parfaites et de personnes perfectionnées.
Voici à quoi ressemble la principale organisation fondamentaliste hindoue
actuellement à son grand rassemblement.
Ça vous fait peut-être penser aux années 30 en Italie ou en Allemagne.
Ce mouvement prend en effet racine dans le fascisme.
C'est un membre du même mouvement fondamentaliste hindou
qui a assassiné Mahatma Gandhi.
Les fondamentalistes hindous considèrent ce meurtrier comme un héros national
et ils veulent ériger des statues à son effigie à travers toute l'Inde.
Ils sont impliqués depuis des décennies
dans des attaques d'envergure contre les minorités.
Ils bannissent livres, œuvres d'art et films.
Ils attaquent des couples lors de la Saint Valentin
et des chrétiens le jour de Noël.
Ils n'aiment pas que d'autres critiquent
ce qu'ils considèrent être leur culture ancienne,
qu'ils utilisent ses images,
qu'ils la caricaturent
ou dessinent des images à son propos.
Mais ceux qui revendiquent le plus haut et fort
cette ancienne et éternelle religion hindoue
sont vêtus de shorts marron et de chemises blanches
tout en affirmant, étrangement,
être la race aryenne originelle,
comme les violents djihadistes salafistes
qui formulent leurs exigences envers leur religion primordiale
tout en portant des uniformes militaires noirs
et des balaclavas.
Ces gens fabriquent des identités pures et immaculées
de conviction et de certitude.
Selon les fondamentalistes, la religion et la culture
seraient leur propriété exclusive, une propriété.
Mais les religions et les cultures sont des processus.
Elles ne sont pas des choses, elles sont éphémères, désordonnées, impures.
Observez n'importe quelle religion et vous verrez des disputes
qui remontent à la nuit des temps.
Toute critique de la religion, sous n'importe quelle forme,
doit ainsi faire partie
de ce vaste sentiment d'humanité
auquel nous devrions aspirer.
Je respecte votre droit d'avoir et d'exprimer votre religion,
votre culture ou votre opinion,
mais je n'ai pas nécessairement à en respecter son contenu.
Je peux l'apprécier en partie
comme je peux apprécier l'apparence d'une vieille église
mais ce n'est pas la même chose.
Pareillement, j'ai le droit humain
de dire quelque chose qui pourrait être offensif,
mais vous n'avez pas de droit humain de ne pas être offensé.
Dans une vraie démocratie, nous sommes offensés en permanence
car les gens expriment tout le temps des idées différentes.
Ils changent aussi d'avis.
Ces avis sont donc éphémères.
Vous ne pouvez pas changer les opinions politiques de quelqu'un
en fonction de leurs origines religieuses, nationales ou culturelles.
Ces remarques sur la pureté religieuse
valent aussi pour le nationalisme et le racisme.
Je ne comprendrai jamais
cette fierté envers votre identité nationale ou ethnique,
envers le hasard de la naissance dans un ventre chaud et confortable,
cette croyance en votre supériorité à cause du hasard de la naissance.
Ces gens ont des opinons très figées
sur ce qui appartient et n'appartient pas
à leur idée d'une culture nationale confortable.
Je vais caricaturer un peu ici, mais seulement un peu.
Je veux que vous imaginiez le supporter
d'un quelconque parti politique nationaliste britannique.
Il est assis chez lui
et il hurle contre les étrangers
qui envahissent son pays
tout en regardant Fox News,
une chaîne câblée américaine
appartenant à un Australien,
sur son poste de télévision sud-coréen
acheté avec sa carte de crédit espagnole,
laquelle est remboursée chaque mois par une grande banque britannique
dont le siège se trouve à Hong Kong.
Il est supporter d'une équipe de football britannique qui appartient à un Russe.
Sa marque préférée de fish and chips
appartient à une entreprise suédoise de placement à risque.
Le credo religieux de l'église qu'il fréquente parfois
est décidé au cours de réunions au Ghana.
Ses sous-vêtements à l'effigie de l'Union Jack
ont été fabriqués en Inde.
(Rires)
Et –
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Ils sont régulièrement lavés et repassés
par une très gentille dame polonaise.
(Rires)
Il n'y a pas d'ethnie ou de culture nationale pure
et les choix éthiques qui s'offrent à nous
sont aujourd'hui bien plus vastes que d'être forcé de choisir
entre la droite raciste et les visions religieuses de droite,
des visions catastrophiques de la culture.
La culture ne concerne pas que la langue, la nourriture, les habits et la musique
mais les relations entre les sexes, les monuments anciens,
un patrimoine de textes sacrés.
La culture peut aussi être ce qui a été décidé d'être de la culture
par ceux qui ont un enjeu politique
à marteler la culture sous la forme d'une prison.
Les revendications d'identité politique sont un appel au pouvoir.
Elles ne sont pas les réponses
aux injustices sociales, économiques ou politiques.
Elles les occultent souvent.
Qu'en est-il du grand nombre de personnes à travers le monde
qui ne peuvent montrer un monument de leur passé,
qui ne possèdent pas les écrits de textes sacrés,
qui ne peuvent se remémorer
les gloires passées d'une civilisation ou d'un empire ?
Ces personnes font-elles moins partie de l'humanité ?
Qu'en est-il de vous, maintenant, qui m'écoutez ?
Qu'en est-il de vous et de votre identité,
parce que vous apposez vos expériences et vos pensées sur une personne permanente
qui avance dans le temps.
C'est ce que vous êtes lorsque vous dites « je », « suis », ou « moi ».
Mais cette idée inclut aussi tous vos espoirs et vos rêves,
toutes les personnes que vous auriez pu être
et toutes les autres personnes
et les choses qui sont dans la biographie de votre identité.
Ils, les autres,
font aussi partie de vous,
ils avancent avec vous.
Votre vous authentique, si une telle chose existe,
est un moi complexe, désordonné et incertain
et c'est une très bonne chose.
Pourquoi ne pas valoriser ces impuretés et ces incertitudes ?
S'accrocher à des identités pures serait un signe d'immaturité
et les traditions ethniques, nationalistes et religieuses seraient mauvaises.
Pourquoi ne pas considérer toutes ces revendications
faites en votre nom avec scepticisme ?
Pourquoi ne pas rejeter les mythes identitaires
qui vous demandent de vous intégrer,
que les politiques et les dirigeants communautaires,
les soi-disant dirigeants communautaires,
vous assignent ?
Sans ces histoires originelles et ces identités figées,
nous pourrions nous mettre au défi de penser de façon créative
les uns aux autres et à notre futur.
La culture s'occupe toujours d'elle-même.
Je ne suis pas inquiet pour elle.
Les cultures sont des processus créatifs, dynamiques
et non des lois et des frontières imposées.
Voici Abu al-Walid Muhammad ibn Ahmad ibn Rushd,
un juge musulman et un penseur de très haut rang à Cordoue au 12e siècle.
Ses écrits étaient considérés
comme profondément blasphématoires, hérétiques et diaboliques.
Longtemps après sa mort,
les partisans de sa pensée ont été pourchassés sans merci,
bannis et assassinés pendant plusieurs siècles
par l'institution religieuse la plus puissante du Moyen-Âge.
Cette institution était l'Église catholique romaine.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'ibn Rush a dit qu'une vérité religieuse
peut aller à l'encontre de ce que votre raison sait être vraie sur la Terre,
mais cette dernière est toujours d'actualité.
Il existe deux mondes de vérité distincts,
l'un basé sur la raison et la preuve et l'autre sur le divin.
L'état, le pouvoir politique et le droit social
font partie du domaine de la raison.
La vie religieuse est un domaine différent.
Ils doivent être séparés.
La vie sociale et politique doit être gouvernée par la raison,
non par la religion.
Vous comprenez pourquoi ses écrits dérangeaient l'Église,
ainsi que certains musulmans pendant son existence,
parce qu'il nous offre une forte déclaration pour la laïcité,
une laïcité qui est normale dans l'Europe d'aujourd'hui.
L'histoire nous joue beaucoup de tours.
Elle compromet nos vérités figées
et ce que nous croyons être notre culture et leur culture.
Ibn Rushd, quelqu'un qui s'avère être musulman,
est considéré comme l'une des influences clés
dans l'introduction et la diffusion de la laïcité en Europe.
Contre les puristes de race, religieux et nationalistes en tout genre,
pouvez-vous adopter son histoire,
pas parce qu'il était musulman,
pas parce qu'il était arabe
mais parce qu'il était un être humain
avec de très bonnes idées
qui ont ébranlé son monde
et le nôtre.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)